en la escuela primaria de sound dijo que
en 2012 un pistolero solitario mató a 20
niños de 6 y 7 años así como a 6
profesores la reacción a rabia
indignación y un llamado al cambio el
atentado hizo que el entonces presidente
barack obama y su vicepresidente joe
biden intentarán impulsar una nueva
legislación que incluyera la prohibición
de los rifles de asalto prohibición de
los cargadores de armas de gran
capacidad o como mínimo ampliación de
los controles de antecedentes las tres
propuestas fueron derrotadas en el
senado una dolorosa derrota para los que
esperaban un cambio significativo
en general este fue un día bastante
vergonzoso para washington todavía
podemos lograr un cambio significativo
para los eeuu pero casi diez años
después el cambio significativo aún no
ha llegado la cámara de representantes
dominada por los demócratas aprobó un
proyecto de ley para un control de
antecedentes más estricto en 2021 pero
el proyecto de ley está atascado en el
senado al no tener la posibilidad de
alcanzar el umbral 60 votos para evitar
el bloqueo el demócrata christopher
suite un fuerte defensor de leyes de
control de armas más estrictas hizo una
emotiva petición a sus colegas
republicanos tras el último ataque
mortal estoy aquí en este piso para
rogar para literalmente ponerme de manos
y rodillas encuentran un camino hacia
adelante trabajan con nosotros para
encontrar una manera de aprobar leyes
que hagan esto menos probable el
destacado republicano ted cruz denunció
las peticiones de cambio poniendo aún
más de relieve la división anders
evidentemente cuando hay un asesinato de
este tipo se ve que los políticos tratan
de politizar lo sabemos por experiencia
que la herramienta más eficaz para
mantener a los niños a salvo es la
presencia de fuerzas de seguridad
armadas en el camino la opinión pública
muestra que más del 50 por ciento del
público estadounidense está a favor de
leyes de armas más estrictas más de 3500
tiroteos masivos se han registrado en la
última década en eeuu después de sandy
hook